just pour we get started with video
today you've clicked on this one you
already knows about a place rather than
a person we try something new we're
experimenting why not this is super
interesting I promise it's like a
biography of Chernobyl the the place and
what happened there I really think
you'll enjoy it and let's get into it at
exactly 123 a.m. on April the 26th 1986
the world suffered its worst ever
nuclear disaster outside the town of
Pripyat in Ukraine reactor number four
at the local nuclear power plants quite
literally blew its top it released more
nuclear material into the atmosphere
than the Hiroshima and Nagasaki
explosions combined the resulting cloud
of death blanketed half of Europe led to
the total evacuation of parts of North
Ukraine and southern Belarus and
triggered a process that would end five
years later with the complete collapse
of the Soviet Union when we talk about
disasters there are certainly a scale of
disasters in this one it ranks somewhere
near the top but how much to most of us
really know about history's worst
nuclear accidents if you go on Wikipedia
right now it will tell you the total
number of deaths due to two Nobel is a
paltry 31 the overall impression that
you get is that it's a disaster that's
notable but not really on the same
league as something like 9/11 but
impressions they can be misleading for
those living in the USSR Chernobyl it
was there 9/11 it affected workers from
each Republic in the Soviet Union it
permanently damaged trust in the
governments and it left behind a deadly
legacy that still being reckoned with
to this very day in the biographic
slidey we're looking at the story of a
town the blew up an empire
[Music]
it was a chilly February day in 1970
when the first brick of the new city was
laid some 90 kilometers north of Kiev
privets was officially under
construction as the ninth of the USSR s
so-called atomic towns places built
solely for the families of those people
working at the nuclear plants in this
case that meant the vladimir lenin
plants just three kilometers north the
plant you know today as chernobyl
lifeand prepared it was far beyond the
standards common in the soviet union at
that time the atomic towns were Moscow's
pride and joy those who lived in them
could expect fully-stocked shops
hospitals with actual equipments and
apartments that were the envy of people
from Vilnius to Vladivostok even by
these high standards proposed it was
something else
former residents still talk of local
forests replete with natural beauty and
wax lyrical about visiting the river
beachfront on sweltering summer days but
from the get-go there was a darker side
to this new city over at the nuclear
plant authorities were quietly
installing RBMK reactors famous back
then for their ability to be converted
to nuclear weapon production at the drop
of a hat this useful ability also made
them incredibly unstable like driving a
car without brakes in only a short time
the reactor rip rip it was going to go
screaming over a cliff edge taking as
passengers right along with it on the
eve of the disaster though everything
seemed to be going well just fine
officially given city status in 1979
privat had grown to a booming metropolis
of 43,000 people with an average age of
only 26 the young population meant no
shortage of weddings and celebrations
and the town had become a hugely
desirable posting for soviet scientists
over at the vladimir lenin nuclear plant
four reactors were already up and
running with a fifth one on the way
former prep it residents later called
those last days a kind of paradise if
that was the case it was about to be one
that was lost forever
[Music]
one of the greatest ironies of the
Chernobyl disaster is that it was caused
by of all things a safety test on the
night of April the 25th 1989
to find out if the newly built reactant
number four could still operate its
emergency water pumps in case of a power
failure
so they disconnected it from all the
fail-safes removed the control rods and
shut off the main power source there is
always a surge that almost immediately
ran out of control in a panic the
engineers tried to reinsert all 200
control rods back into the reactor at
once
this turned out to be a really bad idea
the control rod said graphite tips that
facilitated the unstable reactions that
were already taking place no sooner were
they in the reactor than it was hit with
the mother of all explosions the 1,200
ton cover it was blasted into the air
radioactive debris shot a kilometer into
the night sky two workers in that
control room were just killed
immediately incredibly the survivors at
the plant had no idea that just
triggered a bona fide catastrophe their
geiger counters were geared up to detect
low amounts of radiation exposure the
sort of thing you might normally expect
from working at a nuclear plant when the
reactors spewed forth some of the
highest radiation levels ever seen the
geiger counters they just stopped
working back in prep out the local fire
brigade mobilised nearly 30 men screamed
up to the reactor in their trucks with
no protective clothing on and poured
water on to the fire that was now raging
but the flames they wouldn't go out not
only that the men complains of a
metallic taste on their tongues and the
feeling of pins and needles in their
faces by the time they got home at the
end of their shifts a number of these
first responders were already showing
signs of acute radiation sickness yet
still no emergency was declared when
news reached Moscow at 5:00 a.m. Soviet
leader Gorbachev was infamously told
that the reactor was so safe it could be
placed in the middle of Red Square had
Gorbachev taken them up on that offer
it'd have been a heck of a sight the
ruins of reactor number four were at
this point buried under 14 tons of
highly radioactive rubble and burning
three
thousand degrees it was also spewing
radiation over North Ukraine and
southern Belarus plenty of which was
already finding its way to prep yet it
had been the hot night that night in pre
bats many slept with that windows open
unaware the cancer-causing particles
were now blowing into their bedrooms and
settling on they're exhausted bodies yet
when they woke up it wasn't too
warranted mass panic but to an ordinary
day yes most of these people were
nuclear plants workers and most knew
something that happens but no one knew
the full extent of the disaster as
radiation fell in invisible deadly
clouds children played outside in the
streets mothers went shopping and Men
got ready for work the one discordant
note was the sudden appearance of masked
soldiers on the city streets they stood
in twos or threes monitoring the crowds
and not answering questions it was the
first sign the residents of prep at had
of the nuclear tsunami that was about to
engulf them all by the evening of April
26th radiation levels in prep out were
600,000 times the normal the excellent
documentary the battle for Chernobyl
which by the way is one of the main
sources for this section estimated that
anyone exposed to those levels would
have received a lethal dose interest for
days
clearly the Soviet authorities were
going to have to react since fast a 2
p.m. on April the 27th with the deadly
fire still burning three kilometers away
a thousand school buses were driven into
prep out and parked on every Street
residents were called outside and told
they had two hours to pack their
belongings and prepare to be evacuated
there's been an accident they said don't
worry you'll be away for three days and
we'll sort this all out and then you
could come right back I mean come on
with the Soviet authorities when we lie
to you so provides residents prepared to
leave their paradise they've hacked
quickly taking only what they could
carry
then all 43,000 were loaded onto the
buses and driven away in the vast flat
emptiness of northern Ukraine none of
these people would ever see their homes
again
so now you might be wondering well what
was going on in Moscow while this
nuclear apocalypse was unfolding well
the answer is nothing well at least not
much
the Kremlin did put a scientific
delegation together to study the problem
but aside from that Soviet authorities
basically sat on their hands like a kid
who's farted at a party and tried not to
let the rest of the big countries see
them blushing
unfortunately the radioactive fart
released by Chernobyl was just like a
regular fart in one important respect
its stank not in the eggs in methane
kind of way but the stench of radiation
which is capable of being picked up by
even the most basic of equipment on
April the 28th Swedish scientists
monitoring their own nuclear plants
caught the first whiff of that silence
and very very deadly emission with only
what we can imagine was a figurative
yeah they all turned to the other
countries and said hey guys guess what
the US as large as did now although
Moscow would try the geopolitical
equivalent of whoever smelt it dealt it
for the next 24 hours the jig it was up
on April the 29th the Kremlin came clean
from this point on Chernobyl
became a global emergency it was around
this point that the first responders
arrived in Moscow Hospital number six
the one place in the whole of the Soviet
Union geared up to treat acute radiation
sickness of the 30 or so firemen who had
responded that night 28 would die in
agony their skin burned from their bones
by an invisible enemy in the aftermath
of the first responders deaths an
additional 130,000 people were evacuated
from the towns and villages surrounding
prep out yet even now these Soviet
authorities response remained woefully
lacks in Kiev a mayday parade was held
with the blessing of the Communist Party
despite a change in wind direction
meaning radioactive dust was now falling
on the Ukrainian capital like a deadly
rain one week after the initial blast
the meltdown it was still going on the
fire itself had been put out with sand
but the reactor it continued to burn
meanwhile dangerous readings were coming
in from as far away as Greece and France
it was against this worrying backdrop
that the International Atomic Energy
Agency made its most worrying
announcement of all with the reactor
melting downwards through the plants
Chernobyl
it was on
brink of a full-blown nuclear explosion
time for a quick explainer the water the
first now dead fireman had dumped into
the reactor had pooled at the bottom
with the top of the destroyed reactor
now plugged with sand to contain the
fire any molten radioactive goo that
reached the water could trigger a chain
reaction which in turn could trigger a
nuclear explosion and we're talking
about something in the range of three
megatons here that's 200 times the size
of the bomb that flattened Hiroshima
according to the utterly terrifying
online tool nuke map depending on the
way the wind was blowing this could have
doused not just Minsk but also Vilnius
all the way in Lithuania with
catastrophic levels of radiation were
the winds blowing towards Kiev 95
kilometers to the south it could have
turned the Ukrainian capital into a
silent tuner it was at this point that
they liquidate has arrived in the last
years of the USSR the liquidators were
the equivalent of 911 s first responders
the men and women who were marched into
the jaws of death determined to do their
duty they comprised Army reservists
firemen nurses police officers miners
and pilots plus the scientists and
workers who accompanied them they came
from every single one of the Soviet
republics from Estonia to Georgia from
Kazakhstan to Uzbekistan all told half a
million of them converged on Chernobyl
during the dark days of mid-1986 very
few of them escaped on Scott to read
their story is to read a tale of heroism
and suffering not seen since the siege
of Stalingrad there are the 600 pilots
who flew over the burning reactor
trapping led on it to plug the broken
top who later suffered myriad health
problems there are the 125 firemen sent
beneath the meltdown to drain the water
out and stop the second explosion most
of him got sick and then there are the
ten thousand miners who came from Russia
to create a concrete chamber beneath the
reactor to stop it poisoning the
groundwater 2500 of which would die
before the age of 40 there were men
ordered to clear radioactive debris from
the roof of the power plant where
radiation levels were so high they had
to work in 40 second shifts or risk
receiving a fatal dose miners were
forced to dig in 24 hour shifts without
any protective clothing then there are
the stories of the cleanup
decontamination of the zone itself
the countryside surrounding Pripyat was
so contaminated entire forests had to be
bulldozed buried villages were scrubbed
from tip to toe perhaps most shockingly
special squads were given guns and sent
out into the countryside to shoot all
the dogs and cats lest their radioactive
fur now prove a danger to humans all
told it was one of the biggest cleanup
operations in human history rivaling
even Deepwater Horizon it lasted six
months whereupon a 30-mile exclusion
zone was established around prep at and
it remains there to this very day the
final capstone was the sarcophagus this
was a concrete BAM off that was placed
over the reactor at the very ends of
1986 just as the first snows began to
fall it's sealed reactor number four off
from the outside world completely
ensuring that it would remain safe at
least for a time you see the sarcophagus
it was built in a hurry and it was
designed to only last 30 years
this wasn't seen as a problem as when
2016 finally rolled around the Soviet
authorities would clearly still be in
charge in Ukraine and they'd be able to
replace it with another one I mean it's
not like the entire USSR was gonna
completely collapse in the next half
decade or so right
[Music]
on November the 9th 1989 the world
watched in auras ordinary Germans
toppled great chunks of the Berlin wall
while guards watched on it was the start
of the complete collapse of communism in
Eastern Europe and the final dissolution
of the USSR in Ukraine mass protests
against Moscow didn't break out until
1991 but when they did they did so under
trim Nobles deadly clout in Kiev
protesters were photographed in gas
masks and protective clothing waving
signs referencing the disaster at a
political level the shutting out of
Ukrainians from a disaster in their own
backyard had immense consequences
the most immediate of which was Kiev
declaring independence on August 24th
that year but the fallout from Chernobyl
had effects far beyond Ukraine The
Economist has argued that the huge
economic history SSR took from the
disaster directly led to its collapse
but on the fringes of the Chernobyl
exclusion zone former residence of
Pripyat watched these events with
undoubtedly mixed feelings while their
homes had been lost the authorities had
built them a new city to recreate their
paradise many of them still worked at
the old power plant remarkably the three
other reactors had been restarted by the
end of 1986
apparently danger be damned yet new
cities can't make up for the tall tree
noble took on its Liquidators across the
USSR hospitals had spent the last five
years flooded with those who worked in
the zone today it's estimated that
around a third of these surviving
Liquidators are disabled in some way in
Belarus which got more radiation than
Ukraine one study estimated that as many
as 20% of the adolescent population
suffered birth defects related to the
accident as for the number of excess
cancer deaths Chernobyl caused we simply
don't know the World Health Organization
estimated only 20th anniversary that it
was around 4000 but estimates there vary
wildly one EU report that the number
placed her to 60,000 whatever the truth
the aftermath of Chernobyl has been a
source of anger in Ukraine and Belarus
ever since when the plants other
reactors were finally shut down
following international pressure in 2001
few lamented their passing but the drama
well it wasn't over in the late 1990s it
became clear that Ukraine was never
going to be capable of
be building the sarcophagus when it
finally fails it was at this point that
it became abundantly clear that the
sarcophagus was never going to make it
until 2016
despite being built to last thirty years
the Soviet sarcophagus was already on
the brink of collapse the next 10 years
alone were spent shoring up the old
structure to prevent another catastrophe
then in the mid 2000s and new
sarcophagus had to be built that would
completely contain the old one at a
staggering at 35,000 tons the new
sarcophagus it was a miracle of
Engineering built 300 meters away from
reactor number 4 to limit radiation
exposure it took 10 years to assemble it
then had to be rolled over the old
sarcophagus and completely sealed it was
taller than the Statue of Liberty and
bigger than an Olympic Stadium when it
was finally sealed in November of 2016
it had cost 1.5 billion dollars this one
though it's expected to last the next
100 years during that time robots inside
will deconstruct the old sarcophagus
before finally dismantling and making
the reactor itself safe when the new
sarcophagus finally reaches his end in
2116 it's hoped humanity won't need to
build an even bigger one
today the glistening new structure looks
over a landscape that's very different
from the one reactor number 4 changed
forever in 1986 the ex paradise of
creeped out is no longer just empty but
crumbling away beneath an on sort of
nature the once tame forests are now so
devoid of people that the exclusion zone
has become an accidental wildlife
reserve teeming with wolves bears
beavers and Lynx not the people who have
completely vanished though just a few
short years ago the Ukrainian government
agreed to let a small number of
Chernobyl evacuees back in around 200
now live within the zone itself dicing
with death on a daily basis you can even
go to visit them Chernobyl receives tens
of thousands of tourists a year drawn by
the lure of Ukraine's very own Pompeii
and I actually went to did this last
year and it's well worth doing as for
the disaster itself well it thankfully
remains the worst nuclear accident on
record bad as the Fukushima meltdown in
2011 was it didn't even come close to
Chernobyl's 1986 eruption hopefully
neither accident will ever be exceeded
now normally this is the point where
which wrap-up our biography and say a
few things
just that those credits roll but
Chernobyl story well it's still far from
over
it's estimated that the zone will remain
uninhabitable for humans for another
twenty four thousand years a stretch of
time that's almost beyond comprehension
it was only four and a half thousand
years ago that the pyramids were first
built in Egypt try to imagine for a
moment just how different life was back
then how impossible it would have been
for your average slave to close his eyes
and imagine our worlds to imagine
spaceflight penicillin the internet now
multiply that feeling by a factor of six
you know some idea of the scale of time
left until Chernobyl's effects stop
being felt our story today it might be
over but the tale of Chernobyl is only
just getting started
so I hope you found the video
interesting and there's a little bit
different to our normal stuff but we
thought we'd try a biography of a place
just for a change of pace I found this
one personally super interesting and if
you did like it please do give us a
thumbs up below let us know in the
comments what you think of doing this
sort of video every now and again we'd
love to hear from you and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]